Bernie Sanders has won the New Hampshire primary
election. He narrowly defeated Pete puto
judge last night. They're both going to end
up with the same number of delegates, nine
from a New Hampshire where you will have updated
total delegate numbers and much, much more
coming up. A thank you to the more than a
hundred thousand or so different people that
caught at least some piece of last nights
of results live stream with me on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook live. We had a great time
watching the results develop live. Took a
bunch of phone calls. It was great. Let's
look at the results. And of course Bernie
Sanders jumped to a large lead upfront. If
you were watching live, you saw Bernie leading
by about 12 percentage points towards the
beginning of the results coming in. That lead
shrank over the course of two hours and it
got down to 10 and then eight and six and
five, four, three and then it teetered between
one and a half and three percentage points.
Uh, ultimately ended with Bernie Sanders defeating
Pete by 1.5 percentage points with a popular
vote victory of just over 4,200. Now, because
New Hampshire awards delegates proportionately,
you will notice on screen that Bernie comes
away with nine delegates and boot edge edge
also comes away with nine delegates, six delegates
for Amy Klobuchar who really was the over
performer of the night exactly as expected.
And I want to talk about that a little bit.
Yesterday in looking at the polling, I predicted
that Amy Klobuchar would be the over performer
of the night because if you look at her polling
trajectory, the polls of course ending a few
days short of the primary. In other words,
there were polls released yesterday, but they
had only interviewed people up to a couple
of days prior. And looking at her trajectory,
it was realistic to believe that her surge
continued beyond what the latest polls reflected,
not fully representative of the [inaudible]
surge.
And you Hampshire. And indeed, that's what
happens. So let's now look at polling versus
actual results to see who overperformed who
underperformed. And I don't think you'll find
the results too surprising. As you can see,
Amy Klobuchar over-performing her polling
by a massive 8.2 percentage points. Meanwhile,
Bernie Sanders underperformed by 2.8 points.
Still one Joe Biden underperformed by 2.6
now, interestingly, I got a bunch of emails
from people saying, David, you know, Bernie
was the biggest under-performer of the night
by 2.8 that's true. But Joe Biden's under-performance
also involved Joe Biden finishing fifth, right?
Joe Biden underperformed and finished fifth
and now again, more questions about his viability
in this entire thing. Come up. Bernie Sanders
underperformed by 2.8 but still ended up winning.
So there are a w the the, the meaning and
significance of those under performances are
quite different. Elizabeth Warren gave a strange
sort of [inaudible]. It actually was like
a concession speech, but not just about New
Hampshire.
It was almost like she was conceding the entire,
uh, primary to either Pete or Bernie. She
kept talking about, it's still early, we're
going to fight, but both Bernie and Pete would
be great. I'm going to keep fighting, but
we need to rally around the eventual nominee
implying she knows it's not going to be her
and interestingly enough, Donald Trump saw
it basically the same way. Although Trump
laced his commentary with the discriminatory
nickname, Pocahontas tweeting last night,
quote Elizabeth Warren, sometimes referred
to as Pocahontas is having a really bad night.
I think she is sending signals that she wants
out. Calling for unity is her way of getting
there, going home and having a nice cold beer
with her husband. Uh, this is essentially
my analysis, although I don't refer to Elizabeth
Warren as Pocahontas, but it did seem like
Elizabeth Warren was starting a sort of wind
down.
Also, by the way, somebody noticed as a funny
aside looking at Trump's tweets last night,
that not only did Trump's analysis of the
Warren speech match mine, Trump also seems
to be adopting my pronunciation of Pete boot
edge, edge tweeting quotes, boot edge, edge
parentheses. Budaj is doing pretty well tonight
giving crazy Bernie a run for his money. Very
interesting. I would be shocked if Trump is
actually getting that from me. That would
definitely be something else. So let's talk
delegate totals. Delegate totals. As of right
now, as I told you, insignificant in terms
of the delegate math, you need 1,990 delegates
to secure the nomination. All the current
numbers tell us is that we are starting to
see enough of a split in the delegate math
that if this trajectory continues, no one
will get to 1990 and it will be a contested
convention. We'll deal with that in more detail
tomorrow.
But looking at totals, Pete boot edge edge
now with 22 delegates, he has his 13 from
Iowa plus nine from last night. Bernie Sanders
with 21 delegates. He has his 12 from Iowa
plus nine from last night. Warren has eight
Amy seven and Joe Biden six nobody else has
any delegates. Note that for now, Bernie Sanders
has won the ROV votes in 100% of the primaries
and caucuses, Iowa and New Hampshire. But
Bernie Sanders is not willing winning the
delegate math and that is firing up many,
many people. Uh, Andrew Yang did drop out
yesterday after an abysmal 2.8% in New Hampshire.
We're going to talk about that a little later,
but now we go onto a presidential debate next
Wednesday. That'll be followed by voting in
the Nevada caucuses on Saturday, February
22nd then voting in South Carolina on Saturday,
February 29th and then on the super Tuesday,
March 3rd, which I believe will really give
us a sense of is the trajectory continuing
to look like a contested convention?
Are there really two contenders right now?
It's Bernie and Pete, but you've got a bunch
of people that are still relatively close,
just a few delegates separating everybody.
Um, let's look at those upcoming primaries
and caucuses. We really don't know what the
hell is going on in new in Nevada because
the last poll is a month old. At that point,
Biden was plus one over Bernie. That was a
month ago. Anything could happen in Nevada.
We'd love to see some new polling there. South
Carolina has been widely expected and assumed
to go to Joe Biden for awhile. Now. The latest
poll is 10 days old and it has Biden plus
18 I do believe South Carolina is essentially
a must win for Biden. Now realistically Biden
will stay in at least until super Tuesday
because anything could happen on super Tuesday,
but Biden is not going to do well on super
Tuesday unless he can gain momentum by securing
the win in South Carolina that he has long
been expected to get.
If he doesn't get South Carolina, the Biden
path starts to narrow even more than it has
already narrowed. Not to mention that Elizabeth
Warren has to start picking up delegates.
She's pulling forth in South Carolina. I wouldn't
be surprised to see her end up with zero in
South Carolina. Remember that like with most
primaries, there's this 15% viability threshold
in South Carolina. If you don't get 15% you
get zero delegates. Right now Warren is pulling
eight in South Carolina not looking good.
So there are now in reaction to yesterday's
Bernie win over booed edge edge. There are
all sorts of hot takes about what does New
Hampshire mean for Bernie? What does it mean
for the nomination? And the reality is that
you can spin this almost any way you want
and a lot of people are. So let's go through
now later, we'll talk about yang getting out
and who else should get out.
Let's now talk about the hot takes being floated
around under the guise of being enlightened
think pieces.